madame bulupiy bonjour j'aimerais qu'on
pense surtout des enfants des enfants
c'est des petits malins et nous cache
très bien leurs émotions on ne voit pas
toujours les effets pervers de cette
pandémie de ceux de ce retrait qu'ils
vivent de la vie scolaire de la vie
sociale et sont reclus à la maison alors
il y à des dommages si on tente on
attend des deux frères de docteur julien
dire ça va nous exploser en plein visage
c'est une bombe à retardement pour les
enfants ce que l'on vit en ce moment
chacun vive à sa façon il y en a
effectivement qu'ils vont avoir tendance
à plus cadré ses émotions en inde dont
le verbaliser plus facilement mais c'est
certain que plus les semaines passent
plus on voit des symptômes apparaître
certains septembre augmenté s'étaient
déjà auparavant la période de conflit
donc je vais la mairie mais oui aller
jusque le pardon alors oui c'est
vraiment important d'assurer un suivi
par l'ars a donc essayé de voir ce que
l'enfant est en prennent vie et une
séance façon de pouvoir allier les
accompagner à travers parce que
difficile actuellement madame beaulieu
pelletier c'est d'avoir des réponses des
solutions et vous vous êtes allés de
l'avant vous allez mis en place un petit
guide avec votre collègue frédéric
philippe en mars dernier on est deux
mois plus tard et ce guide vise
justement à gérer les impacts
psychologiques chez les enfants alors
qu'est ce que vous suggérez justement en
gros pour que ces impacts soient
amoindris piste mais c'est sûr si on
regarde effet très content on va être
plusieurs semaines avec les enfants à la
maison
alors ça va être vraiment important de
mettre en place une routine une routine
près viser beaucoup d'insécurité
beaucoup d' imprévisible il peut en deux
on sait pas trop ce qu'il ya devant nous
alors ce qu'on peu remplies précise et
pour l'enfant ça sera déjà ça donc si
chacun sait ce qu'il fait dans sa
journée par une façon trop rigide mais
au moins d'en avoir une bonne idée déjà
ça vient rassurer l'enfant
si on peut légalement aussi puis lui
offrir l'opportunité d'un verbaliser ce
qui vit donc de mettre en
certains disaient vents vont être plus
ferme et à
aborder ça donc des fois c'est
simplement d'offrir un espace potentiel
pour accueillir l'enfant donc pas
nécessairement de précédentes en
question de comment semble pas non plus
en mer tôt mais on va voir s'ils ont pu
offrir une présence potentielle
d'effacer simplement d'aller s'asseoir à
côté de l'enfant dans sa langue est en
train de jouer mon lit où on est c'est
simplement et on offre une ouverture
mais je vous parlais la routine on
l'entend dû beaucoup cette routine elle
est important de oui mais si l'enfant ne
veut pas de la routine
dis moi je vois je n'en veux pas au
coach nba
je suis tanné de ma routine on fait quoi
mais à la base je l'encouragerais ferme
à ce que cette routine de soit mise en
place
en famille donc vraiment que les besoins
de chacun en ce moment soit identifié
pour pouvoir justement arriver à faire
une gouttière qui qui plaît à tous donc
puisqu'on peut inclure l'enfant attend
le conseil la présence de la famille la
famille peut devenir un cadre étouffant
aussi en vous avez les parents qui sont
en télétravail en ce moment qui vivent
des difficultés elle c'est pas évident
perte de revenus tensions familiales
alors on s'en remet présentés parfois la
cellule familiale comme la solution
miracle mais au contraire à ce moment on
a l'impression que c'est une marmite qui
bout y ait autant de mecs mettre le
couvercle sur la marmite avec des succès
parfois mitigés ont clairement
puis effectivement si cette routine la
haye limites dans un cadre familial où
il ya une séance dangereux qui sont
présents bon là on sera pas capable à
tenir de toute façon cette routine en a
remis comme parent c'est important de
regarder justement ce que nous on vit
comme ça pour essayer de partager
qu'est-ce qui viennent d'un enfant c'est
quoi lancer le nord
quelle somme ils anxiété les sources
d'anxiété à moi en ce moment pour
arriver à départager ça pour être
capable éventuellement bd de répondre
davantage aux besoins de l'enfant
c'est ainsi de baisser nos standards
berne humain envers les enfants c'est le
beau dire de rien faire ça veut
simplement dire que c'est un contexte si
particulier on doit s'y adapter
donc comme parents aussi il ya certaines
choses qu'on fait est actuellement qu'on
peut peut-être mettre la [ __ ] un peu
plus douce être plus indulgent aussi
avant les espaces de solitude ans a
besoin d'être une pièce différents mais
un espace qui est des moments où chacun
va pouvoir avoir cette solitude c'est
essentiel comme parent aussi que ça ça
nous aide en lien que nos enfants c'est
pas se mettre la pression de devoir être
disponible en tout temps
c'est difficile vous dit pas se mettre
la pression c'est difficile permettez
moi de vous interrompre
mais je prends la balle au bond j'ai moi
même des ouvrants là ça m'interpelle et
c'est difficile de pas se mettre la
pression parce qu'il ya une énorme
pression actuellement parce qu'on veut
que nos enfants réussissent on veut que
l'année scolaire soit quand même viable
pour eux dans la mesure du possible
alors cette pression là comment est ce
qu'on fait pour pour cela seul enlever
des épaules on est moins sévère on
encadre - les tâches qu'on exigeait
auparavant on les laisse de côté une
fois créé peut-être le voir un peu
différent ce qui prime en ce moment
c'est le bien-être des enfants de la
famille alors déjà de deux rues de
relativiser puis doit de se dire qu'est
ce qui est vraiment important manche
dans le courant des prochaines semaines
cette gare il y en ait de mettre le
plaisir à l'avant plan donc oui
d'arriver à rendre les activités plus
ludiques pour les enfants non mais on
avait certaines attentes de certaines
tâches
rendons soul music essayons de trouver
des façons créatives de rendre le tout
plaisant c'est sûr que l'impression
qu'on se met pour les apprentissages
scolaires mais il y en a qui vont se
mettre la pression de faire toute la
journée dans le contexte c'est
nécessaire 200 m l'important c'est que
la fin sans qui développe ce sentiment
courbe est un vrai comme on dit en bon
québécois en cela qu un peu en france
d'où une louche 11 jean
pour vous avez mis en place également si
je trouvais ça très intéressant l'idée
de bulles sociale expliquez-nous un peu
là en quoi ça consiste exactement alors
que c'est pas c'est pas décemment
concept qui vient de monter c'est
vraiment une idée qui est de plus en
plus répandue de dire mais est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas arriver par exemple dans
des familles qu'ils sont plus
restreintes on pense à des parents avec
un enfant unique ou parents
monoparentales avec un deux enfants
parce qu'on ne peut pas par exemple à
arriver à ce qu'on veut en mettre deux
familles ensemble un chacun on respecte
une quarantaine au prêt alors on danse
on y est et on vit de façon isolée donc
consommer des contacts extérieurs
ensemble au moins de recul et certains
de certains échanges qui sont essentiels
on a besoin actuellement de retrouver
cette ce contact
alors on est des êtres sociaux on eu
besoin de ça alors oui plein de façons
qui existe des façons créatives on peut
aussi utiliser les plates formes
virtuelles mais cette idée aussi de
tranquillement renouer des liens d'une
façon sécuritaire en respectant les
normes mais et on doit être créatif dans
certains coach du mans pour soutenir la
santé mentale
on les éloigne des infos de la télé
de rdi malheureusement est ce que c'est
important pour les enfants de ne pas
être surexposé aux mauvaises nouvelles
parce que les mauvaises nouvelles il y
en a à la tonne en ce moment et ça a un
impact est essentiel c'est important
pour tout le monde de quoi se surexposer
que les enfants en particulier s'ils
veulent regarder les nouvelles on le
fait de façon accompagne on peut aussi
sélectionner ce qu'on va leur montrer et
faire attention que c'est aux
conversations et qu'ils attendent c'est
pas juste les nouvelles c'est aussi on
nous téléphone avec quelqu'un ou pas par
une plateforme web on y entre et parler
comme adultes à un autre adulte et notre
enfant qui joue calmement à côté absorbe
ou soutien capte tout alors il peut
nécessairement en mesure de tout
comprendre mais cette charge
émotionnelle de faire aussi attention
une dernière question il nous restera
secondes l'om est disait hier écouter
les trotteurs on ne sera pas capable
d'endiguer ce virus ne va falloir
apprendre à vivre avec donc ce sont des
années en avant de nous on dit ça comme
à nos enfants qu'ils vont devoir vivre
avec le virus pendant peut-être le
restant de leurs jours
en fait je pense qu'on d'abord on
s'adapte à leurs questions on leur
présente très simplement pas d'une façon
paniquer mais on l'a redit l'état des
choses que effectivement c'est un virus
qu'il est qu'on apprend à connaître
puis au fur et à mesure on va s'adapter
on répond question au rythme de l'enfant
on va pas au delà de ce qui est prêt à
en temps si poser la question c'est qui
est présenté au fil des mois des années
il nous proposera aussi des questions
non pour à ce moment là aussi la
compagnie traverse mais merci beaucoup
je ne viens vous beaulieu pelletier de
nous avoir donné un petit peu plus
d'outils à mettre dans notre coffre pour
parler à nos tout-petits parce que c'est
tout un défi en ce moment merci
infiniment synthétiser au revoir